we need more women entrepreneurs we need
more women in business find your passion
and really get behind it and and don't
give up there's so many times when it
seems insurmountable but if you have the
wherewithal to keep the hard work going
and and really understand that you can
make a difference it's well worth it a
friend of mine when I first did my first
article in The New York Times she called
me up Jane Rosenthal and said the
article is great but you shied away from
the word ambition and you should never
ever shy away from that word again and I
think that's great advice for women I
think women should be just as ambitious
as men and be proud of it from the
fashion standpoint I think it's very
important to have a unique point of view
and there's a lot of competition and
it's a saturated market and I think that
if there's always room for great
companies if it's different and you have
your own point of view and a unique
style and and that's what I think you
have to focus on is the end of the day
it's about the product it has to be
great and it has to be different and not
too referential of what else is out
there
one thing that we speak a lot about in
our company regardless of the tremendous
growth we have had is restraint and I
have never regretted saying no to
something whether it's different
collaborations or partnerships or
opening a store or whatever it may be we
we are a very patient company and we
want to always look to the long-term so
when I talk to entrepreneurs I always
speak about that and say how important
it is to really think forward and and
not just take what comes along and
really be thoughtful in building your
business